1960 fünf jahre nach der unterzeichnung
des staatsvertrages verabschiedet der
damalige verteidigungsminister graf
österreichische soldaten zu ihrem ersten
internationalen einsatz
es ist ein sanitäts kontingent für den
kopf
1964 beginnt die zypern mission mit
einem feldspital 1972 folgen
militärische truppen um ein aufflammen
der kriegerischen tätigkeiten zu
verhindern
1974 beziehen teile des zypern
bataillons die golanhöhen in syrien als
un-beobachter truppe
1991 kuwait un-beobachter einsatz nach
dem zweiten golfkrieg und anschließend
einsatz eines logistik und in genf
1996 beginnt in bosnien der einsatz
einer transport kompanie seit 2004
unterstützen soldaten und der eu
kommando die aufrechterhaltung eines
sicheren umfeld
[Musik]
1988 erdbeben hilfseinsatz in armenien
startschuss der gründung der
katastrophenhilfe einheit after 1991
iran errichtung eines fällt spitals nach
einer humanitären flüchtlingskatastrophe
1997 polen trinkwasseraufbereitung für
die bevölkerung nach schweren
überschwemmungen
1999 albanien aufbau eines fällt spitals
für vertriebene des bürgerkriegs im
nachbarland
1999 türkei nach einem schweren erdbeben
erfolgt ein such rettungs und berge
einsatz des bundesheeres
2000 mosambik nach schweren
überschwemmungen wird ein
trinkwasseraufbereitung cele mend
entsendet
tsunami katastrophe 2004 das bundesheer
stellt in sri lanka die
trinkwasserversorgung für die
bevölkerung sicher
seit 1999 unterstützt das bundesheer im
kosovo die aufrechterhaltung der
sicherheit durch überwachungs und
sicherungsaufgaben
2002 afghanistan zur aufrechterhaltung
der sicherheit für die bevölkerung und
der arbeitsfähigkeit der regierung wird
ein bundesheer kontingent entsendet
2009 um eine terror mission um
vertriebenen flüchtlingen zu helfen
2011 libanon unterstützung des us
einsatzes mit einer logistik
österreichische soldaten stehen seit 60
jahren weltweit im einsatz als garanten
für sicherheit